infinity is a puzzling concept not the notion of potential infinity that numbers go on forever but the concept of infinity as an actual complete manipulable object does infinity really exist or is it just part of the fabric of our imaginations assuming actual infinity leads to unsettling consequences numbers like 1 2 3 4 are countably infinite but between each of them say between 1 & 2 there is an uncountably infinite continuum of real numbers such as 1 point 1 1 point 1 1 1 point 1 1 1 1 and so on the two sets real numbers and counting numbers are both infinite but have different sizes some infinities are bigger than others so does actual infinity exist or just the idea of potential infinity most people simply ignore the paradoxes which lie in abstract realms with few practical or scientific ramifications but for some mathematicians their presence raises concerns and might unravel the foundations of the entire field of mathematics